الصعب أن أنقل عمق معاناة الشعب السوري، لقد
كنت بالفعل منزعجًا ومحطمًا للغاية
[موسيقى]
الزلزال الذي ضرب قبل أكثر من
ثلاثة أسابيع يضيف معاناة يمكن تخيلها
للأشخاص الذين عانوا بالفعل
أكثر من 12 عامًا من
اقتصاد الحرب  انهيار وباء كوفيد-19
وتفشي الكوليرا المستمر
[موسيقى]
شكرًا لكم،
نعتقد أنه يجب استخدام أي معبر
لمساعدة الشعب السوري، يمكن أن
يكون عبر الخطوط، يمكن أن يكون عبر الحدود، عبر
الحدود، هناك المزيد من الفرص  في
الواقع أفضل، لذلك إذا كان هناك
أي وصول ينبغي استخدامه
لمساعدة الشعب السوري، ولا
أعتقد أنه مع الصناعة الحالية
ستكون كافية
للأجانب.
[تصفيق] [
موسيقى] لقد
بدأنا بالفعل في رؤية بعض
الحالات المشتبه بإصابتها بالكوليرا والتي  في الحقيقة
ليس علامة جيدة ليس فقط لشمال غرب
سوريا ولكن لسوريا بأكملها ولكن أيضًا
للقرية بأكملها
[موسيقى]